a lot of times and this is not knocking
workers because it was like it's like a
lot of times you know I used to tell my
white dude friends I go you guys gotta
understand you don't have as much game
as we do they said what do you mean I
said a lot of times girls get with you
because it's the easy way us we're
always everybody is trained not to [__]
with us but we still get you you know
how much gain you gotta have when you
come out at defensive come on the chess
piece which is the defensive chess piece
the black piece white piece gets to go
first feel me right right you know it's
what I'm saying I feel it but a lot of
times they feel what girls will date
white guys because it's just easier and
you know whatever because they're white
there's no they didn't have no game or
nothing I'm not saying white dudes don't
have any game but usually when I dudes
have game they've been hanging around us
do you play chess no okay Checkers he's
really good are you really good I suck
at it who's good at chess Bobby Bobby
really I'm not good I just know how to
play it no no are you really no you got
to know Agnes Carlson and ping pong I'm
gonna ping pong too I can play people
you play ping pong yeah I'm ping pong
I was in a Chinese ping pong Club in
Chicago when I was nine I'm not my
teacher's Chan and I had and I I held
the I but the paddle I held it like this
yeah yeah like this right and then I
need I used to do it like this but I
held it like this that's the that's the
forehand I mean it's the forehead and
it's the backhand and I was in Shanghai
right visiting we were in Beijing and
Shanghai and I went into a Starbucks
and I was like I was going to the
bathroom I go it was this ping pong
table in Starbucks wow I was like and my
buddy knows his white dude he goes
there's people and they said this
[__] people I said do you play people
he goes no I go damn this is amazing and
so I go and then the lady and um the
manager it was pretty empty she goes she
didn't speak English you want to play
video I said yeah yeah so I'm playing
against the manager of Starbucks she
ripped you apart I beat her wow it was
20 20 20 I think it was 1921 and I beat
it these Chinese people coming in going
like who's this black dude I'm like and
I won and she gave me all this free [__]
I was getting a lot yeah she gave me all
this cookies
wow it's like wow so good
it was great yeah so I was teaching in
ping pong I wish I was better if I would
when I was younger I played all the time
but if I would have stuck with it Judah
friedlander but that's all he plays he's
a master because you know Susan Brandon
has a well she was dating a guy that
owned a ping pong place it's called spin
in New York yeah I met Susan Sarandon at
Starbucks and I was like hey Susan I
said excuse me I said you you know about
the spin are you part of the spin she
goes you like Ping Pong I go yeah she
goes come here she grabs my hand I'm
walking with Susan Sarandon for three
blocks wow down the spin wow downstairs
where she was dating and she goes this
guy likes ping pong wow and so he goes
you know Judah friedlander does a lot of
competitions here but you know lucky at
Starbucks yeah ping pong related I
always go I'm in the mood for Life Frank
Caliendo
Frank is good at ping pong you know
where else he's a master uh Sebastian
Maniscalco there's no way we played in
we did uh just for last Bermuda and it's
boring as [__] Bermuda and it's me
and Sebastian he goes you want to play
Pink
oh my God
and we're playing and he was making me
laugh he beat me because I heard me
laugh because he was so dramatic he goes
five four
and Paul I'm really I was really good in
when I was young I was really good in
pool because you played it all the time
and you're literally don't have a job
you're just like pool my brother was me
and my brother good in pool you know
video games and and the ping pong was my
[__] though pool is for Filipinos that's
our national sport pool is that yeah
yeah pool was my [__] like I was [__]
yeah my buddy my other buddy we were
just like dope in that [__] long shots
yeah well guess what what I gotta go
pick up my car yeah what car it's in a
[__] shop what kind of is it a Tesla
no everyone has a it's a it's an Audi
Audi 5000. shake it up but can I say
something I like the chemistry between
you you everyone in this room I'd like
to do this again one day yeah